and lately we've seen one of my
favorites cate blanchett play the
goddess of death and thor ragnarok and a
glamorous thief in ocean's 8 but Kate's
new role suits her best because she's
simply magical in the house with a clock
in its walls I'm relieved to see you
didn't inherit your uncle's freakishly
oversized head huh
says the woman who literally looks like
a q-tip Kate's a witch and Jack Black is
a warlock in the fantasy film based on
the best-selling book when you guys get
the script for a movie like this is it
an easier yes because you know your kids
are gonna be able to love it and think
you're the coolest for this type of film
there's certainly brownie points that
you hope you're gonna win but then when
it was Jack I thought this is gonna be
something
I think I'm smarter than you because I'm
smarter than you
[Applause]
there's a lot of magic in the movie but
will be too scary for Cates for kids and
Jack's too there is one really
horrendous nightmarish image yeah which
is both hilarious and terrifying it is
weird but it's worth boiler alert she's
talking about my favorite scene of the
movie yeah and maybe it is because it's
me as a baby but it's adorable and
horrifying at the same it is it's
horrifying adore fighting sometimes I
hit it out of the park we shot our
interview at Hollywood's famed Magic
Castle a private club for fans of magic
have you been to the Magic Castle before
yes I have been to the Magic Castle with
my kids and when I when people do magic
tricks in front of me I scream you love
it
why are literally scream now I have a
magic trick all right I've worked very
hard on this I can't possibly think of
what its gonna be
it is so good yeah so I'm not quite as
magical as this cast I'll keep
practicing I think it's all on the
wrists in the house with a clock and
it's walls just hit theaters today
[Music]